Now that you know the various ways to
read and write from Firebase, you might
have noticed that to update a piece of
data there are a lot of moving parts.
You can call a write
method to update the data,
then the data's changed
in the Firebase database.
This triggers your listeners
which you've added, and
finally the UI is updated.
With so much going on, when you're
trying to debug what might be going
wrong anywhere in this process,
it can be a little tricky.
So let me tell you about a helpful
method that I've been using to track
what my code is sending and
receiving from the Firebase database.
So here I am in my
ShoppingListApplication class.
If you find like you need to debug your
app you can type the following in.
Firebase.getdefaultconfig.setloglevel.l-
ogger.level.debug.
This turns on Firebase's debug mode.
And in debug mode, you get a printout
of useful data in the logs
about what is sent to and
received from, from Firebase.
So let's run the app and
see this in action.
With the app up and running,
I can open up the logcat output and
change it from Verbose to Debug.
Okay, so I've cleared the logs.
I'm going to go ahead and
add a shopping list.
And we can see here that,
in the logs, I actually
get a lot of information about what
was just set and where it was set.
I made this list called Let's Go
Shopping with an anonymous owner, and
here's the timestamp info.
And here it shows the data
that was being sent through,
you can scroll over a little bit.
And if I go over to my dashboard,
I can see that it has in fact
been sent to the database.
Knowing how to both use
the debug logger level and
to make sure that you keep checking
what's going on in the dashboard,
will help you really make sure that
your app doesn't have any bugs in it.
So now, whenever you run into a bug,
you can always try turning on the debug
logger level as well as comparing
what's going on in the dashboard.